millions of Americans in the central us
are watching for a new round of extreme
weather that could bring tornadoes and
flash flooding 27 tornadoes have been
reported in just the last 24 hours
yikes rivers in at least three states
are at record flood levels at least 15
deaths are blamed on this weather since
last week and a weekend tornado
devastated El Reno Oklahoma this twister
tore through a mobile home park killing
at least two people take a look at what
one Motel looked like before the tornado
hit this is what's left of it now
Omar Villafranca is in El Reno which is
just west of Oklahoma City Wow Omar
those pictures good morning good morning
this twisted piece of metal around me is
all that's left of the Jeep dealership
here now this storm happened on Saturday
at night under the cover of darkness
while people were getting ready to go to
bed and it was moving the National
Weather Service says this was an ef3
wind speeds topping 165 miles per hour
only on the ground about four minutes
but it traveled roughly two miles and
that's all it took for this storm to
destroy a large part of this small
community from the air you can see the
path of destruction of the tornado as it
cut through a local motel and shredded
mobile homes at this trailer park I felt
like I was falling or trying to fall off
the bed or bouncing sadana jeans was
inside a trailer with her nephew when
the tornado blew her home off its
foundation and sent her neighbor's home
tumbling I looked out straight out the
window and which was busted and saw my
neighbor neighbor's trailer
that home was packed with at least a
dozen people including children but
everyone inside survived two people from
the trailer park died rescue crews
searched the debris field Sunday for
possible victims buried in the rubble
amazingly no one died at the nearby
American budget value in even though a
large section of the two-story motel was
demolished at least 29 people were
injured some seriously it's all hands on
deck situation El Reno mayor Matt White
says the city will recover from Mother
Nature's one-two punch just a week ago
floodwaters damaged parts of the town
now a tornado it's a very trying time
for us give me through it on Sunday more
than 100 miles away from El Reno outside
of Tulsa the town of Sapulpa was hit by
a twister that tore up homes businesses
and power lines
it's very emotional because
a lot of things could have happened that
didn't so understand for to the Lord
this morning for being here Oklahoma
Governor Kevin stood is expected to
visit El Reno today but people here are
not waiting for any help they've already
started cleaning up in fact the local
VFW is acting as a shelter the Red Cross
is here helping people in need and this
whole state is already ready under a
disaster declaration and there is no
rest because there is more severe
weather in the forecast for later this
week
Anthony tough week for Oklahoma Omar
thank you very much